[Music]
and almost got away news submitted by
mr. X loves JK Thank You eggs just like
a porn star one of UK the most wanted
men was on the run for 20 years in the
US I mean he got away from us that's
crazy good like the u.s. people go to
Mexico on the run and UK people go to
the US on the run its history repeating
itself criminals coming to the United
States for freedom I don't even know why
you would come to a first world country
if I was on a run I'll go to a third
world country she could pay people off
and then their police is way more
unsophisticated even though they want to
do their jobs and if he's a little boozy
maybe the u.s. is a third world country
to the people from UK oh that's true no
because you're though like a pound is
more than the dollar oh that's a ride a
courtesy is so much lower especially if
you went to like Alabama or something
so this story's about this man named
Eddie Mair he's nicknamed Fast Eddie
back in 1993 he was working like with
the security truck and so he was in
charge of like transporting money hey if
you did it in Sarge oh this is what any
look like back then 37 years old at the
time so job with transferring money yes
oh and at security charter when I ready
you spoke and stole money and you sit
for 20 no that's bad it could have been
your money that truck looks like a piece
of [ __ ] does it look like it sucks if
you pay my fee looks like a [ __ ] like
Toyota previa with like letters on it I
feel like what the personal weapons that
I have at home I could take that truck
over if I thought for in my street in
1993 yup
they better coming off and tanks I see I
should I'm [ __ ] robbing them that
[ __ ] looks stupid you're not you have
morals
yeah that money's mine yeah
those little armored trucks though they
got a whole bunch of people inside a
whole loads of weapons those ones were
crazy that one looks like a piece of
[ __ ] so they just looks like a square
little thing and then when you see them
transfer money you see all the dudes
walk out with it it's kind of
frightening like they'll [ __ ] murder
you even come anywhere near them that
one looks like a murder dice cool shut
that's what it looks like one night he
was at a bar or a pub and he was talking
to someone and then somehow in the
conversation it came out that he liked
his job what he does and then they were
just like oh you must you must be
getting away with a couple grand here
and there huh they must not notice and
then she was drinking some more I handed
up clipping out all that he was like no
if you really want the money you just
gotta take the van or the you know the
truck these monsters ended up finding
out about him and who he's like who he
is where he lives what he does for a
living they showed up to his house one
day these three gangsters and told on
like alright we're going to be working
on a little project together and then
laid out the whole plan and so then the
day of the heist or I guess incorrect
his partner goes into the bank that they
were going to one of the mobsters pull
up into a beautiful car like his old
bucket and then they were like alright
you guys follow me so then he ends up
taking off leaving his partner in the
bank he takes off with 1.2 million
British pounds which is about 1.6
million dollars so then the mobster
pulls up next to him tells them I follow
me so then they end up going somewhere
and they transfer the money he says it
took like 30 seconds to transfer all
that money into the p-doped arrange
second yeah and they were just dirty
they were doing it in a residential
street to where there was no cars
passing by Blake and the other strange
missing cards happening they tell them
to get into the different car and then
they take his beat-up car and they end
up doing this to it they burn it to
shred Oh evidence in order to shreds
okay not friends but they turn it I just
feared it almost both I just
they just made it to taki clark tataki
mmm delicious so they did that to his
car and then they took him to an
apartment and that was where he laid low
for a whole week and then he said it he
was laying on the floor he was in the
apartment for a whole week he was in
hiding dead em until eight loads with
his army crawling into I didn't dare to
stand up he saw the whole story unfold
on TV like that was like the biggest
heist in British history at that point
and so he was big news and then so he
says of the monster showed back up to
there his home here he has come on its
base they told him all right we're gonna
go get you a passport so then he went
out he took a picture of his new
passport and it ended up looking like
this so this is this is his account of
this story okay okay
because he's he's written a book
everything he went through
why don't work you work like ronald
jenkees yeah yeah that's why girls break
you know like what's the first thing he
says I could give him the most
ridiculous looking glasses I looks like
he's got it I got a comedy store or
something
so much Candida and then he has like his
Gras so he took this passport Victor
they gave him the fake name was Stephen
King he's like are you kidding me you
couldn't have died like a lesser-known
oh my god kid you know the thing about
this that's crazy in a Castel so he's
saying like then they took him into a
car that he gave him his cut of money
which the whole time during this whole
thing he never knew how much money he
was going to get but they ended up
giving him a hundred and twenty five
thousand British pounds oh that's a lot
better that's a good cut we had a ninety
that turned out to about a hundred and
sixty thousand US dollars value today at
two hundred and seventy thousand dollars
oh that's pretty [ __ ] good great well
he stole 1.3 million pounds right - yes
Oh 1.2 L - si he had percent so you only
get to 10% cut and he doesn't get to die
before all this happened he had sent
away his girlfriend Debbie and their
three-year-old son to the US and so
there were already shares on a vacation
but she didn't know until he told her
all right we're going to end up meeting
in Dallas so she went from Boston where
she was to Dallas and the name it up and
that's when he told her were actually on
the run because I did all this [ __ ] and
so then that definitely started living
their life in the u.s. on the run this
is Debbie Wow he looks exhausted he
changed her name to Sarah King so now is
Sarah and Stephen and then this is what
their little three-year-old at that time
we hmm
his name is Lee goddamnit old grandpa
face that baby looks sad
that is a weird-looking Chuck just a a G
oh that [ __ ] baby ugly dude you're
brave you're crazy because I would not
see anything bad about other kids cuz
I'm scared like my own kids yeah what a
bar baby comes off [ __ ] ugly well I
already knows what a colossus look at
your face
so angry I already know my baby's ugly
he's damaged I'm Angela planning and
Colorado they settle down for a couple a
contagious picture that baby dude it was
just a bad moment for the baby I just I
got this whole story so point is he
ended up getting a plane
this is everywhere he went through the
u.s. while he was on the run I can't go
into detail anymore he went through all
these days at the end of it this is how
they looked towards the gears well he
shrunk like crazy she kept getting
taller but it looks like now I'm 61
years old so the way he got caught was
because leaves ex-wife because he isn't
abroad not a few or super rebellious
because he kept asking questions about
his life like his family back in the UK
they kept giving him the runaround and
iqp he never got a straight answer
instead of rebelling he fathered a lot
of children he ended up marrying some
girl that girl apparently he got drunk
one night he drunkenly told her he
thinks his father is a fugitive and at
this point this man he had already
change his identity to his brother's
identity because he need a green card in
order to work as a money right
on in lalala there's so much the story
that's a lot of information yes
so anyways at the end that ex-wife they
got in a fight or something so she went
to the police and said you ratted him
out with a dude she ended up googling
the name and found articles on him and
noticed that there was a reward and so
she went to police tournament I
guarantee you that if a guy wouldn't be
doing that though of course what are you
talking about guys are [ __ ] no that's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] right there
I know but guys are [ __ ] - I wouldn't
do that so siya I'm telling you right
now a guy wouldn't have done that of
what a guy would have done was just
murdered his wife no they can't do that
no a guy would his murdered his wife and
then got them buried it and they got
caught later for it that's a smart thing
to do it is a smart thing to do it guys
are [ __ ] - so you aterna in 2012 he
was extradited to the UK he was
sentenced to five years but he only
served two years one and he's just not
allowed to return to the u.s. em at the
end oh man I feel bad for the guy but
mr. part uh so his son drunkenly I told
his ex-wife okay you can tell his son
without talking at very young age
that didn't like a drunk ass old man
that was a son
uncle the daughter that was the kid that
end-around excellent having his ex-wife
rat him out and I thought even enough
money to like be on the run with though
I thought he was like on the run with
one point you know what everyone thought
the entire country thought the same
thing and then that's why I like ended
up writing a book in here explaining in
that book the monsters had most of it
yeah exactly and they just went back to
their underground life like money was
never recovered so he just had to get
like a normal job right after he came to
these states yeah so she kept getting
like what is it the time like under the
table kind of wrap it on in tables
peanuts and cash jobs you know for
people that have British accents the US
is a perfect place for you guys to come
because you know why no one thinks that
people with British accents are
criminals here how's it going guys don't
forget to like the video because if you
don't
I will break your [ __ ] legs thank you
so much for the last video don't forget
to click right here or I'll break your
[ __ ] arms quick right here guys
[Music]